[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire le gouvernement a présenté
aujourd'hui en conseil des ministres un
projet de loi pour prolonger le passé
dit terre au delà du 15 novembre
éventuellement jusqu'à cet été je
rappelle que président de la république
déclare apte il ya six mois en avril
dernier que le passé ni terre ne serait
jamais un droit d'accès qui
différencierait les français qui ne
deviendrait jamais obligatoire pour
accéder au restaurant au théâtre ou au
cinéma bref ils disaient le contraire de
ce qu'il a décidé quelques semaines plus
tard on a le droit de changer d'avis
même quand on est président de la
république
certes mais les citoyens en retour le
droit de se méfier de s'inquiétait des
conséquences de la pandémie sur notre
démocratie
dans un rapport sur les crises
sanitaires les outils numériques trois
sénateurs dont il pas écrit noir sur
blanc c'est une dictature sauvent des
vies pendant qu'une démocratie pleure
ses morts
la bonne attitude n'est pas de se
réfugier dans des projets position de
principe jamais nous n'avons été aussi
contrôlée par l'état cpt depuis
l'apparition du cope de 19 le jeu en
vaut-il la chandelle pour en débattre
nous avons invité permettons vous êtes
chercheur en santé publique à l'inserm
vous êtes à l'origine des révélations
sur le sel caché dans l'alimentation et
de la première étude sur la mortalité
liée au chômage dans un pays comme la
france aujourd'hui vous publiez 2084
pourquoi l'état joue avec notre santé
chez human sciences dans lequel vous
expliquer que si l'état a pris tant de
mesures pour lutter contre le coc vide
19 ou les accidents de la route ou le
terrorisme ou la drogue qui tue pourtant
moins que le cancer ou les maladies
cardiovasculaires c'est pour mieux nous
surveiller nous contrôler ou nous
enfermer c'est pour cela d'après vous
que le gouvernement veut prolonger le
passage du ter jusqu'en juillet où c'est
parce que le virus n'est pas encore
vaincu comme l'expliqué olivier vers ans
et qu'il faut rester vigilant écoutez
moi je préfère ne pas faire de procès
d'intention comme ça
a priori le pass sanitaires pour moi
c'est le point d'orgue d'un processus
qui qui qui qui s'étend sur une très
longue période
depuis des dizaines des décennies par
lesquelles l'état en effet cherche
clairement à contrôler les individus
tout en ménageant
c'est à dire en gardant un contrôle
minimal sur tout ce qui est entreprise
ou intérêts économiques j'espère qu'on
en parlera tout à l'heure donc moi je
cette prolongation ne m'étonne pas a
priori comme ça mais je préférerais
reparler une fois qu'on aura démontré ce
que fait ou ce que ne fait pas l'état
pour l'épreuve de santé de sécurité et
menuires je vous êtes philosophe
professeur d'éthique médicale à
l'université paris-x fake les membres du
conseil stratégique cos vite 19 pour la
région ile de france vous mais publié
chez rs une démocratie endeuillé ces
sous-titrés pandémie premier devoir
d'inventaire et c'est la suite d'une
démocratie confiné qui était paru en
janvier vous y analyser la gouvernance
de la pandémie et les conséquences des
choix politiques qui ont été faits sur
notre vie démocratique alors exemple le
passage du ter dont vous parlez dans
plusieurs chapitres que penser de son
prolongement jusqu'en juillet prochain
vous rappeler que le pass c'est un
passeport c'est ça qui m'avait intrigué
au départ à la liberté d'aller et venir
uniquement dans notre société mais pour
les gens dans des pays démunis de
l'accès à la vaccination n'ont pas la
possibilité d'avoir ce passeport ça pose
un problème éthique de la discrimination
pour moi déjà à priori et on voit
aujourd'hui que des personnes en
situation de vulnérabilité non pas se
passe donc ne peuvent plus vivre dans la
société j'ai à dire d'un point de vue
égalité d'un point de vue accès aux
droits qui sont nos droits fondamentaux
d'ailleurs ça avait été mentionné très
rapidement dans la mise en oeuvre du
poste sanitaire dont certaines personnes
ne pouvaient même pas aller chercher la
nourriture dans les magasins ça va
beaucoup frappé c'est à dire comment une
mesure qui est une mesure pour moi
importante à la mesure effectivement où
ça aussi favoriser la vaccination donc
c'est un effet secondaire totalement
positif comment cette mesure nous
interroge sur ce que sont nos libertés
et notre compliance pas accepter cette
soumission
un ordonnancement qui interroge voilà
aujourd'hui c'est assez surprenant
comment les gens sont volontaires dans
la capacité d'admettre le pass
sanitaires la vraie question si la crise
s'aggravait rien n'empêche de penser qu'
elle peut aussi s'aggraver quelle mesure
supplémentaire mettrait tout en oeuvre
dont on est d'ailleurs un certain de
l'efficacité puisque c'est pas en tant
que telle de passer sanitaire qui
aujourd'hui nous permet d'avoir des bons
résultats c'est la vaccination et les
mesures de protection individuelle ou là
donc c'est un débat de fond mais ce qui
m'intéresse le plus c'est
l'acceptabilité des sociétés mais moi ce
qui m'intéresse le plus dans ce débat en
l'occurrence c'est même un niveau au
dessus c'est jean revient à cette phrase
qu'on a trouvé dans ce rapport écrit par
trois sénateurs est ce qu est ce qui est
préférable au fond c'est une vraie
question une dictature qui sauvent des
vies ou une démocratie qui compte ses
morts et
ça tout à coup ça s'est mis à résonner
dans nos têtes à tous depuis le début de
cette pandémie
écoutez déjà ce qu'on peut dire c'est
que la démocratie en effet elle compte
c'est morin parce que je suis désolé
mais il faudrait donner quelques
chiffres ça me paraît très important
pour éviter d'être manipulés et
d'essayer de comprendre un peu le monde
dans lequel on vit
je les quelques chiffres sont les
suivants je ne jouais pas en abuser mais
si on prend la période des 20 dernières
années
des problèmes comme les infections donc
essentiellement la grippe et
et l'épidémie de kobe dans france ont
fait à peu près 600 mille six cent mille
morts
les accidents de la route ont fait à peu
près 90 mille victimes morts au cours
des vingt dernières années
les drogues illicites ont fait à peu
près 7000 7000 morts et le terrorisme a
fait à peu près 300 310 morts bon j'ai
pris cette période de 20 ans pour
pouvoir inclure le terrorisme parce que
comme le voyez évidemment le nombre de
morts liées au terrorisme n'a rien à
voir par rapport aux autres causes de
mortalité
en si on veut donner des chiffres pour
plus plus parlant aux gens si on ramène
ça donc aux ogives journalier donc hier
aujourd'hui comme demain vous avez vous
aurez donc à peu près dont dix morts sur
dix morts sur les routes aujourd'hui
vous aurez à peu près un mort par
overdose et vous aurez à peu près où
derniers chiffres je crois 50 peut-être
50 50 morts par park au vide ou et où
bientôt par grippe
je voudrais les mettre en parallèle avec
les 800 morts en moyenne qui vont se
produire qui se sont produits
aujourd'hui à cause de maladies
cardiovasculaires
ou de cancer
800 morts dont une bonne centaine on
avait moins de 65 ans
et ces morts-là ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas seulement des morts
vous avez à peu près donc au même moment
deux mille 2000 personnes qui ont eu un
accident cardio vasculaire dont ils ne
sont pas morts donc un infarctus du
myocarde par exemple ou un accident
vasculaire cérébral
et ou chez qui on a diagnostiqué un
cancer
donc si vous voulez vous avez ici donc
le lait des chiffres qui vous montre
quel est le poids respectif de ces
causes de de maladie et de mortalité
est ce qui est très important à mon avis
c'est de prendre conscience de ce que
fait l'état pour certains problèmes qui
existent bien évidemment comme le
terrorisme l'épidémie de covin les
accidents de la route ou la consommation
de drogues illicites et ce qu'il ne fait
pas pour des causes de mortalité de
morbidité donc qu'ils sont beaucoup plus
importantes en l'occurrence des
accidents cardiovasculaires et les
cancers
et qui là où effectivement on peut
compter les morts donc au cours des
vingt dernières années il ya eu six
millions de personnes qui sont mortes de
maladies cardiovasculaires ou de cancer
donc on peut parler presque sans jeu de
mots de low cost mais sur une vire
dirait que tu as dit d'une manière à mon
avis un peu rapide est-ce qu'on est dans
une dictature par ce cri impasse
sanitaire mais je suis pas du tout je
sais pas ce que j'entendais la macif
tension est rentré dans une dictature
cette nouvelle fait pas avec le pass la
question de la dictature solitaire s'est
posée dès l'instant nous a empêchés de
sortir de chez nous et on l'accepté on
dans la grande majorité d'entre nous en
se disant toute façon ça ne durera pas
nous n'avons pas de sortir de chez nous
armés dans mon analyse s'il y avait
remise en cause des valeurs ou des
principes de la démocratie on pourrait
d'ailleurs analysé le phénomène c'est
peut-être dans l'absence de débat de
concertation et de vie jédir
démocratiques notamment de vie
parlementaire de concertation de
consultation il aurait pu y avoir aussi
des états généraux à la suite du projet
du premier confinement où j'aimerais
juste revenir d'un point sur cette
notion de dictature je crois que une
pandémie n'est pas démocratique voilà un
phénomène aussi globale à interroge et
révèlent nos sociétés à la fois dans
leur capacité et la vie démocratique
rappelez vous pendant le premier
confinement elle est extraordinaire en
terme de créativité sur le terrain mon
les gens se sont mobilisés se sont
approprié ce que l'état n'était pas en
capacité de faire puisqu'on n'avait pas
anticipé donc premier point on avait une
phase de vitalité démocratie qu'est ce
qu'on en a fait après dans une
gouvernance solitaire et secrète puisque
finalement c'est un conseil de sécurité
sanitaire qui rend j'ai le dire ces
arbitrages sans du reste à voir quels
ils sont les arbitrages vous savez que
la défenseuse des droits claire hédon a
demandé à ce qu'on connaisse aussi des
critères selon quels critères et savoir
avec la question de la vie et savoir
avec la question de la mort donc premier
point l'impression que la vraie
interrogation c'est comment retrouver
une vie démocratique et est-ce qu'on va
prolonger un état d'exception sur des
motifs qui ne sont pas fondées pendant
des mois et des mois notamment en
période électorale on a une
présidentielle est ce que la vie
démocratique sera au rendez vous où est
ce qu'on va trouver toutes sortes
d'avatar ou de prétexte pour nous
empêcher de vivre démocratiquement un
moment d'autant plus important après la
crise qu'on a vécu est peut-être qu'il
va se prolonger et se retrouver dans
d'autres aspects un deuxième point je
vais dire par rapport au chiffre est
vrai que un des éléments qui moi m'a
consterné m'a choqué c'est à la sortie
du premier confinement c'est les prises
de position de grands intellectuels de
gens qui respectent comme andré comte
son lit d'à ils ont dit en substance je
caricature on a finalement sacrifié la
jeune génération est d'être konami pour
sauver des personnes qui de toutes les
manières allait mourir je rentrerai pas
dans le détail mais si j'ai un hommage à
rendre au chef de l'état sait qu'il doit
considérer leur au départ c'était un peu
maladroit malhabile au niveau des
pratiques les personnes qui résident
dans des ehpad à peu près aujourd'hui
six cent mille personnes dans les ehpad
à des personnes dignes de notre
sollicitude et de notre solidarité
d'ailleurs ces personnes qui ont
bénéficié des premières doses vaccinales
c'est quand même ces personnes qui ont
fait notre société est souvent certaines
d'entre elles n'ont même défendu face à
des périls qui mettait en cause des
valeurs de la démocratie donc je trouve
que dans mon approche et dynamique sur
ce point on peut effectivement comme
andré comte sponville dire combien de
personnes mal de tuberculose combien
personnes mortes de cancers pense que
chaque mort est singulière dans sa
signification ce que je termine sur un
chiffre est évident et il était quand
même très sensible aux chiffres de
l'insee donc l'insee a dit que entre
2019 et 2020 donc les chiffres de 2020
on n mortalité en france 2 668 personnes
plus 9,1 pour cent par rapport à 2010
neuf s'interroge aussi comment une
pandémie un moment donné ébranle
également une société avec une
perception de la mort qui a été pour
beaucoup modifié par les annonces
rappelez-vous du directeur général de la
santé qui pendant
des semaines quand on était dans la
période de confinement a donné en
quelque sorte et montrer à quel point
cette mortalité c'est à dire personnifié
quelquefois 7 et comment il ya une
pression comment il ya eu aussi peu tard
probablement une manipulation des
opinions à travers cette pression que
représentait le chiffre ou le
chiffrement qu on déchiffre est pas
d'ailleurs de la mortalité on attend à
ce que le pouvoir l'état et les médias
donc se mettre à égrainer aussi chaque
jour donc les 800 morts par accidents
cardiovasculaires les cancers qui je le
rappelle c'est fondamental sont
évitables évitable dans la quasi
totalité est évitable tout comme peuvent
l'être des morts par accidents de la
route la différence on pourrait dire
entre les morts car d'une part mais lady
cardiovasculaires cancers accident de la
route
ou terrorisme c'est qu' il ne faut pas
contagieux au fond il s'agit pas d'une
épidémie
le traitement de l'état les mesures
qu'on capri l'état pur pour lutter
contre l'épidémie de copie de mon point
de vue ne sont que l'aboutissement de
mesures qu'il avait déjà prises pour des
problèmes qui ne sont pas épidémique
comme la sécurité routière la
consommation de drogues illicites ou le
moule terrorisme enfin je ne sais pas
vous mais met en effet les mesures
prises contre le coc vide c'est le c'est
l'apothéose sais je puis dire on peut
plus sortir de chez nous on peut plus se
déplacer à l'endroit ya un couvre-feu
bon il faut à face à li té à un masque
sur la figure même en extérieur alors
que ça l'efficacité n'a jamais été
démontrée en extérieur bon c'est
effectivement c'est caricatural mais
avant ça si vous voulez a fâché pas si
vous roulez un petit peu sur les routes
de france mais si vous faites de 100 à
300 kilomètres sur une route ce terreau
de secondaire départemental ou national
la vitesse est un facteur accidentogène
très clair sur les routes mais lorsque
vous conduisez sur ces routes là la
succession de pannes au à 30 50 70 80 90
110 puis dans l'élite c'est
insupportable c'est totalement
insupportable c'est
je ne sais pas vous mais lorsque vous
allez dans un musée à chaque fois faut
ouvrir le sac à l'aéroport faut quitter
ses chaussures
voir les militaires qui circulent dans
les rues et c'est bon tout ça ça ça ça
met une certaine ambiance là il y avait
toujours y avait pas d'épidémie de
corrida ce moment là alors évidemment al
ce moment là les gens vous parlent de
sécurité sécurité icare garry ce mot
circulerait sécurité sait pas trop ce
que ça veut dire la sécurité d'ailleurs
pour moi c'est très proche de la santé
mais bon alors là par contre avec avec
la crise sanitaire en effet là ils ont
trouvé le mot santé donc là alors c'est
en étant en réalité je me permets juste
dans les chiffres qu'on donne
habituellement pour la mortalité pour le
cancer en tout 130 1868 de personnes sur
les chiffres qui sont soit conseillé
voilà donc les chiffres peu importe on a
des morts jédir privé si on veut casser
des histoires individuelles
là on a eu la mort public d'une certaine
manière et dans un contexte de fragilité
sociale ou finalement la seule
visibilité on avait de la puissance en
quelque sorte du virus c'était en terme
de mortalité morbidité et dans des
contextes où la mort s'est très mal
passé aussi c'est l'air de rien mais
c'est pas uniquement la mort en soie
avec des victimes c'est quelles ont été
les conditions de la mort dans des ehpad
quelles ont été les conditions de la
mort même d'un produit anthropologique
quelle a été la dignité du défunt
notamment à travers le décret du 1er
avril 2020 l'histoire de mettre les
personnes dans les body bag sans que les
familles puissent les reconnaître alors
nous on a mis en place toute une
réflexion avec les personnes endeuillées
aujourd'hui on a à peu près cent dix
huit mille personnes qui sont victimes
bucovine 19 ans tous les cas considéré
comme mort du clae on aura des chiffres
un peu plus robustes nord dans les mois
qui viennent et puis on a aussi à
considérer ceux qui ne sont pas morts de
la preuve 19 mai qui n'ont pas bénéficié
des égards de tous ces rites qui sont
quand même font date yves de la société
je crois que c'est un élément à prendre
en compte dans notre perception de ce
qu'ont été les morts de la copie 19 un
dernier point que je venais juste
apporter on parle de notre société
française et en fin de compte
le ms donc on est à peu près au chiffre
est à quatre millions cinq le nombre de
victimes au plan international et le ms
dit c'est à minima 3 fois plus donc ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que quand
on a relativisé en nous parlant de
grippe asiatique enfin on peut toujours
trouver effectivement des éléments pour
dire que la médiatisation avec les
chaînes continuent tout un ensemble de
facteurs font qu'on a une perception
différente c'est la première fois que
tout le monde entier veut se trouvaient
confinées c'est aussi des éléments à
prendre en compte mais je dirais que
dire aujourd'hui qu'il y à peu près 12 à
15 millions de personnes ils sont mortes
au jour d'aujourd'hui de lakovic 19 il y
a eu l'amplification des précarités des
vulnérabilités et rapport de l'oit et
sont de ce point de vue il est tellement
accablant donc la réalité de cette
pandémie c'était un phénomène global
total me paraît relever d'une approche
un peu différente de ce que serait par
exemple le cancer l'obésité enfin qu'on
considère aussi comme un phénomène
épidémique puisque c'est toucher
normande personne alors pas tout à fait
d'accord
sur les bords du lez mort par maladie
cardiovasculaire ou les morts par cancer
c'est au moins aussi pire que les morts
parko vide lorsque vous mourrez d'un
cancer généralisé ou d'un cancer du
poumon vous ai tous faits de la même
façon
lorsque vous avez un infarctus du
myocarde qui va ensuite vous traîner
pendant plusieurs années avant de
développer une insuffisance cardiaque ou
un accident vasculaire cérébral
vasculaire merci un accident vasculaire
cérébral c'est la première cause de
handicap physique en france chez
l'adulte deuxième cause de démence
intellectuelle donc cessé il ya cent
cinquante mille par an
en france un toutes les quatre minutes
par rapport au bord du vide il s'agit
pas de faire des comparaisons d'ailleurs
simplement de voir ce qui est fait pour
ces mordus cowitz qui a été fait pour
ces bord des quais vides et ce qui n'est
pas fait pour les morts de cardio
vasculaires ou ou pas aux parents c'est
pour vous interrompre justement parce
que c'est le point de central de votre
livre c'est de dire au fond si on cède
temps intéressé aux que vides si on a
fait tellement de loi contre le
terrorisme si on a tellement légiférer
réglementés contre les accidents de la
route c'est parce que l'état veut nous
surveiller nous contrôler et d'où nous
enfermer mais j'ajoute il pourrait faire
la même chose sur les maladies
cardiovasculaires le cancer nous en paix
nous interdire de fumer nous interdire
de manger de la viande ça il le fait
à un mot monsieur hirsch a tout à fait
raison le problème des maladies car de
mercerie cancer c'est qu'ils ne sont pas
visibles
les hôpitaux sont pleins de ces gens là
simplement ils n'arrivent pas tous en
mode moment il ne sature pas forcément
le service de réanimation d'urgence
comme l'a fait le vide et donc et en
plus sur tous les médias connaissent pas
quoi en gros un bon alors que le coe
vide vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure on a
parlé tous les jours bon c'était c'est
le matraquage alors évidemment quand
vous matraquer les chiffres comme ça a
été fait qu'est-ce que vous voulez que
les gens
enfin je vous rassure avant qu'on
confident france on regarde l'italie
encore un peu avant garde et la chine et
on se disait c'est ça nous arrivera
jamais oui oui tout à fait mais si vous
voulez c'est comme ces couples et les
attentats terroristes si vous voulez
kick sens dramatique bien évidemment
avec les victimes et autres mais
lorsqu'on regarde les chiffres et
lorsqu'on regarde la couverture
médiatique et autres qui qui qui autour
de ça
est ce que c'est un raisonnement de
santé publique non c'est pas du tout un
raisonnement de santé publique on est
bien d'accord
sur la question ce que fait l'état que
ne fait pas état contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires les cancers alors là
c'est très intéressant si vous voulez
les les
qu'est ce que devrait faire l'état pour
lutter contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires et les cancers alors
c'est par exemple une cause majeure de
ces pathologies c'est des mauvaises
conditions de travail
donc une façon d'améliorer
considérablement de diminuer la la la la
fréquence ces pathologies c'est
d'améliorer les conditions de travail
dans les entreprises publiques ou
privées supplié que c'est moins facile
que de réglementer le défendent la
vitesse un arôme km heure voilà là il
n'y a pas grand monde pour le faire
d'ailleurs il suffit de voir ce que fait
l'état donc si on prend par exemple le
nombre d'inspecteurs du travail parce
que pour faire ça il faudrait qu'ils
aient plus inspecteurs du travail plus
de médecins du travail il faudrait que
des comités qui eux dont dans l'objectif
est justement de s'assurer que ces
conditions de travail ne sont pas trop
détériorée qui était le comité d'hygiène
et sécurité et des conditions de travail
le chsct
voilà voilà des choses qu'il faudrait
faire actuellement l'état ce qui fait
celle inverse on réduit les inspecteurs
du travail ont réduit le nombre
d'inspecteurs du travail le nombre de
médecins du travail ont fait disparaître
les ch c'était
donc en fait on ne fait strictement rien
pour améliorer les conditions de travail
au contraire on les laisse se détériorer
donc elle ne dépendront plus que du taux
de profit que peuvent faire les
entreprises donc peu importe après la
santé des travailleurs on le retrouve
d'ailleurs dans les réformes
actuellement cours que ce soit la
réforme sur l'assurance chômage qui est
actuellement
en qui a pris qui avait pris ses qui est
en vigueur qui a été appliquée vous avez
ici une réforme vous cherchez un revint
un paragraphe sur l'état de santé des
chômeurs alors on sait fort bien en
france comme ailleurs que le chômage est
un facteur de surmortalité majeur je
viens d'arriver de le dire même topo
pour la réforme sur les retraites ce que
vous dites est très recevable et
j'arrive à le comprendre notamment la
difficulté d'accès à la prévention mais
c'était la même chose pour la crevette
19 ou les personnes en situation de
marginalité lullaby de vulnérabilité
sociale vous ne pouvez pas peut même
dire jusqu'à la caricature que l'état ne
fait rien vous avez un plan sans cancer
vous avez d'un cas qui se mobilisent et
dans tous les points que ce soit baissée
je vais pas sortir les chiffres donc il
y à une mobilisation tout à fait
évidente la vraie question par rapport
puisqu'on parle de lakovic 19 on s'est
retrouvé dans une situation où tout le
monde était potentiellement menacés
voilà d'une certaine manière il est à
dire sans véritable réponse avec un
système de santé qui a fait
remarquablement face mais dans des
conditions évidemment de pratiques
dégradé et de saturation c'est des
éléments comme aiment à prendre en
compte et on était face à l'imprévisible
juste par rapport au cancer et vous
savez pas ce que vous travaillez ça avec
attention aujourd'hui on a des
stratégies thérapeutiques
ils sont accessibles à tous dans notre
pays quand même il faut le dire
l'immunothérapie on a tout un ensemble
de registre le plan avc avec les
personnes avec eux les samu et non ce
que je veux dire je suis pas en train de
faire un plaidoyer pour les tables on
peut pas dire que rien ne se fait et qui
a véritablement la gabegie dans ce
domaine je me permettais juste de
revenir par rapport à la question
centrale que frédéric le tdi nous a posé
est ce qui s'est passé quelque chose
d'exceptionnel dans le contexte
notamment de la première phase de la
pandémie en termes de mobilisation
médical de maux des buts de mobilisation
scientifique moi je pense que iana daisy
une analyse à mener c'est à dire on a eu
un fake c'est un phénomène exceptionnel
internationale et je trouve qu'on
devrait analyser quel les réponses
qu'ont apporté à des situations qui
paraissait profondément inacceptable
parce que subite pourquoi je dis ça
parce que qu'on le veuille ou qu'on le
veuille pas et vous savez très bien on a
intégré aussi une certaine forme entre
guillemets de fatalité par rapport à
septembre de maladies certaine façon la
y avait quelque chose de laufon
d'erreurs pardon non mais on a intégré
une certaine manière d'un point de vue
sociétal vous parlez des cancers
maladies cardiovasculaires je pense que
ça fait partie d'éléments qui interroge
là on avait quelque chose d'inédit et on
avait une société puis deux communautés
médico scientifique était attestée dans
ses capacités de faire face et je trouve
que de ce point de vue là globalement
les choses se sont passées d'une manière
très constructive
le beau gosse qu'on va faire une pause
mais allez-y
les maladies cardiaques et cancers ça
concerne comme pour les morts déco vite
ça concerne tout le monde il n'ya pas de
spécificité c'est quelque chose qui est
plus prononcée chez les gens socialement
défavorisés également un comme pour les
mordus qu'ovide donc moi je vois pas de
différence majeure entre ces deux
phénomènes de deux de ces deux faits de
ces deux causes de mortalité et de
morbidité
le point important sur lequel moi je
voudrais vraiment insister dire que
l'état fait quelque chose sur la
prévention de ces maladies là c'est
vraiment une mystification vraiment une
mystification
quand vous voyez le déluge législatif
qui entoure la sécurité routière le
terrorisme la consommation de drogues
illicites
et l'épidémie de coded et les moyens mis
en place pour faire appliquer ces lois
moyens humains et techniques c'est
extraordinaire c'est absolument
fabuleux moi je veux dire c'est
l'essentiel des forces de l'autre tous
les ministères des sommes absolument
incroyable demande d'ailleurs comment
ces jours autant de drogues en france je
veux dire c'est incroyable quand on
regarde par contre le les textes
législatifs qui permettrait de contrôler
les teneurs en sel en graisses ou en sel
dans les aliments transformés de faire
en sorte que les buralistes arrête de
vendre du tabac aux mineurs de faire en
sorte d'arrêter de faire la publicité
pour des aliments déséquilibré ou pour
des boissons alcoolisées dont on sait
qu'elles font à peu près 40 mille morts
par ans
y'en a pas
aucun texte de loi et lorsqu'il ya un
texte de loi
aucune mesure pour les appliquer que ce
soit en termes d'inspecteurs du travail
deux inspecteurs de d'agents des douanes
ou d'agents de la direction générale de
la répression des fraudes dont les
effectifs ne font que diminuer je vous
interromps là on fait une pause on prend
ça juste après
[Musique]
que représente concrètement l'industrie
et de l'armement dans l'économie
française se lier avec est sûre je lis
tic et puis c'est quelque chose qui l'aï
mise en scène plus eu une réalité ça
faisait longtemps de ce contrat et paix
remis en cause sur les sous marins moi
j'ai tendance à privilégier si vous
voulez l'explication géopolitique on est
aujourd'hui dans une situation où les
américains font acte d'autorité et on
est bien en peine si vous voulez de
savoir comment on peut répliquer l'achat
de sous-marins nucléaires par les
australiens déstabilise fondamentalement
toute la zone asie pacifique c'est à
dire que les américains décident de
faire de la prolifération de pair
chose qu'ils interdisaient jusque là est
ce qu'aujourd'hui on a les moyens en
france de riposter face aux états unis
non on est aux ordres des américains
les ong sont devenus 50 ans des acteurs
incontournables de la société moderne
par leur impact auprès des gouvernements
et du public confondant régulièrement
les grands principes avec leurs
objectifs politiques
ce sont des organisations non
gouvernementales mais pas des
organisations non politiques les ong
développent des stratégies d' influence
qui privilégie l'émotionnel sur le ratio
le sectarisme de la majorité d'entre
elles les amènent à des interprétations
qui exclut toute pensée ou comportements
n'allant pas dans leur sens et leur
ambition n'hésitant pas à tordre les
faits et à utiliser tous les moyens pour
imposer leur vérité
[Musique]
on reprend un autre débat avec pierre
meneton chercheur à l'inserm qui publie
2084 pourquoi l'état joue avec notre
santé
emmanuel hirsch qui est philosophe
professeur d'éthique médicale et qui lui
public une démocratie en deuil et je
vous donne la parole emad venir je
voulais réagir à ce que venait de dire
qu'hier même ton juste avant la pause se
trouvait d'abord le propos tout à fait
important en terme d'information et je
ne conteste pas du tout les données
la vraie question
si on prend lakovic 19 on a été très
intrusif par rapport à l' intime très
intrusif en termes de décisions qui ne
se discutait pas il ya peu vraiment de
négociation avec le public c'était des
impératifs on a évoqué au début le pass
sanitaire c'est à prendre ou à laisser
je résume la situation est ce que demain
ça va pas inciter l'état est beaucoup
plus intrusif non pas dans la prévention
mais dans les dictats sion offrir les
diktats d'or qu'elle se soit de règles
justes d'exemple au
tchad vient à dire d'abord il peut y
avoir des pressions très fortes on a vu
pour les prélèvements d'organes par
exemple pourrait très bien dire si vous
continuez à fumer vous n'avez pas le
droit à la sécurité sociale s'il faisait
des complications ja pour
responsabiliser les gens et un deuxième
point à voir des interdits un peu plus
fort plus contraignant encore pour les
personnes en terminant sur un point et
on voit très bien les personnes les plus
vulnérables sont celles qui sont les
moins réceptifs finalement l'information
de la communication
donc ça va accentuer encore les
injustices donc comment vous voyez
l'équilibré à trouver entre libertés
individuelles j'ai le droit si je veux
de fumée je sais très bien à quoi je
m'expose et au nom de quoi l'état va
m'interdire on l'avait vu d'ailleurs
puisqu'on parlait du pass sur la 5e rue
la ceinture de sécurité puis ce qu'on
faisait en fait l'on sait par exemple
que la ceinture de sécurité
et rappelez-vous claude legault wc tout
ce travail sur l'accidentologie on ya le
rationnel et l'irrationnel jusqu'à quel
point les libertés individuelles doivent
être respectées même si elles sont
délétères pour les personnes et coûteuse
pour la société en termes par exemple
d'accompagnement des personnes jusqu'au
terme de leur vie quand ils sont
atteints d'une maladie incurable
sachant que les plus jeunes ne s'en
souviennent pas b
la poubelle l'obligation de la ceinture
de sécurité a créé les mêmes les mêmes
réactions de rejet que le pet sanitaires
pour la prévention des maladies
cardiovasculaires des cancers des
maladies chroniques en général il s'agit
surtout pas d'augmenter les contraintes
sur les individus elle existe déjà à ces
contraintes les mesures les plus
emblématiques contre l'alcoolisme par
exemple où loulou le tabagisme ça va
être d'interdire aux gens de fumer à tel
ou tel endroit ou de boire dans tel ou
tel contexte donc l'exemple de l'alcool
est parfait si vous voulez hein on va
empêcher les gens de boire ou telle
quantité d'alcool ou de ne pas boire du
tout dans certaines situations par
contre on continue à faire de la
publicité pour l'alcool sans aucun
problème
la question de la prévention des
maladies cardiaques et cancers c'est des
mesures contraignantes non pas sur les
gens il faut vraiment leur lâcher la
grappe c'est justement ce qu'on discute
de ce soir mais sur les acteurs
économiques
et hélas il ya tel pour la confiance que
par contre ils sont très très très très
très conscient et très actif pour éviter
justement toute mesure contraignante sur
leurs activités donc c'est la façon de
prévenir les maladies cardiovasculaires
les cancers faire en sorte que les
produits mis sur le marché soit moins
nocif que les conditions de travail
soient moins dégradée
voilà les mesures à mettre en place pour
lutter contre les maladies
cardiovasculaires les cancers pas
d'introduire des contraintes
supplémentaires chercher chez les
personnes
l'exemple de que vous citez sur la
sécurité routière je trouvais
particulier en illustre hâtif en effet
les contraintes qui s'exercent sur les
conducteurs donc
sont de deux types en fait un si on veut
bien le regarder ces les contraintes par
exemple concernant la vitesse où la
consommation d'alcool en effet des
facteurs accidentogènes
qui peuvent porter atteinte à autrui en
provoquant des accidents
le port du casque dans une sur une moto
ou la ceinture de sécurité dans une
voiture c'est relativement différent
d'un par nature puisque là c'est pas
forcément accidentogène pour autrui en
fait vous protéger les gens contre eux
mêmes avec cette philosophie là on va
pouvoir arriver à un moment donné à
faire en sorte qu' il faudra tout les
gens soient obèses 1 parce que s'ils
sont obèses ils risquent de tomber
malade ça va pas aller 1 donc que deux
mêmes droits il faudra qu'il fasse
regarde les physiques en 2 2 font que
vous posez vous dépose d'une manière un
peu transversale en éthique médicale
comment une personne peut s'approprier
des connaissances développer une
expertise qu'on appelle une expertise
profane et se responsabiliser par
rapport à un souci qu'elle a d'elle-même
en respect qu'elle a d'elle-même et
aussi la société et moi je pense qu'on
est dans un environnement planétaire
assez intéressant parce qu'on voit
qu'elles risquent aujourd'hui une
société démocratique la planète à
l'environnement nous confrontent et
l'impression qu'il ya une prise de
conscience aujourd'hui et ramène à une
certaine forme de réflexion éthique
individuelle me semble-t-il ce que je
regrette par rapport à la pandémie c'est
qu'il n'y a pas eu de pédagogie de la
responsabilité partagée il n'y a pas eu
de rapport entre ce que l'état a
préconisé quelques fois bio bon escient
et puis une société dont on a dit au
départ c'était le ministre d'éducation
nationale qu'elle était à prenantes donc
on reste un peu sur notre faim et donc
pour revenir ce que vous dites pour moi
ce qui m'intéresse c'est comment à
travers un certain nombre de dispositifs
permettre des personnes de s'approprier
des savoirs et d'être reconnu dans une
capacité d'intelligibilité et ce qu'on a
observé que même mes nerfs sinistre ces
18 mois c'est le discours très
descendant paternaliste infantilisant
réducteur prescriptif y compris à
l'égard de professionnels par exemple
dans les établissements comme les ehpad
qui a une compétence ans avoir été
révoqué du jour au lendemain c'est le
côté administratif
j'ai les dires de la gestion avec des
règles et des protocoles des procédures
qui n'ont même pas été soumis à une
expertise a priori j'allais dire l
évaluation a posteriori
l'impression finalement d'une avancer à
tâtons mais avec un autoritarisme qui ne
se discutait pas et on voit maintenant
les effets sur le terrain c'est à dire
comment d'abord et par rapport à quelque
chose est important que vous évoquez en
créant creux de votre propos par exemple
la critique des experts et vous êtes
spécialiste de santé publique dans des
domaines a priori aujourd'hui c'est pas
uniquement le fait des réseaux sociaux
il ya une telle suspicion sur
l'expertisé scientifique et c'est pas
lié uniquement aux médias qui ont mis
quelques fois en scène des aspects
contradictoires ou qu'on a vécu en
direct la science en marche pourquoi il
s'est dit à une suspicion pense que
préside la république est aussi pour
beaucoup quand il a choisi ce qu'il
prenait ou pas dans l'expertisé quelques
fois mis en cause l' expertise
scientifique c'est des éléments à
prendre en compte donc la question que
je me pose par rapport à ce que vous
dites d'une manière plus globale sur la
santé publique et sur le droit la
personne de disposer d éléments qui lui
permettent j'ai à dire à la fois un
diagnostic une argumentation
un discernement et d'agir dans son
intérêt propre quel type de modalités on
devra mettre en place avec quel type de
procédure de prod2 processus on a bafoué
la démocratie sanitaire pendant 18 mois
et c'est intéressant je passe une bévue
mais l'introduction du dernier livre que
j'ai fait j'ai demandé à gilles pialoux
raison que qui est un infectiologue à et
sur votre préface et on parle des années
sida et on a connu une pandémie d'accord
on a connu une approche politique de la
pandémie c'était grâce au milieu
associatif qui s'est approprié pour des
raisons qu'on va pas développer la
question en amont on a vu comment on
pouvait aborder démocratiquement une
certaine pour des et c'était le cas du
vih sida comment également avec les
accords de doha on a permis l'accès aux
antilles il y avait toute une expertise
on peut se poser aussi la question
pourquoi on a révoqué a priori les
démocratie sanitaire ce qui aurait été
d'ailleurs très favorable à ce qu'on
était plus près c'est là mais c'est une
question on avait tout de suite à une
intelligence y avait tout un ensemble de
dispositifs ya des grandes associations
par exemple qu aurait pu éclairer le
processus décisionnel les personnes qui
du jour au lendemain ne pouvais plus
aller en consultation tous les
laissés-pour-compte à tous toutes les
personnes qui ont été déclassés du jour
au lendemain avec vous parler de cancer
ont gardé des études qui sont faites sur
la morbidité et de la mortalité
liée au fait que des personnes pendant
la période de confinement et après ont
été déprogrammés en termes de santé
publique ça c'est des questions qu'on
aurait pu anticiper j'ai déraillé pas
chez vous aussi permanente on sait que
au delà d'une crise sanitaire on a vécu
une crise organisationnel c'est à dire
que tout à coup tout ce sur quoi on
était à peu près sur tout ce que l'on
pensait qu'ils allaient marcher ça c'est
pas du tout près de passer comme ça et
qu'au dernier moment on a dû décréter le
confident alors qu'on pensait que
c'était bon pour les italiens et les
chinois avaient pas porno tout ça s'est
passé très très vite qu'on n'a pas de
vous plus pensé qu'on allait re confiné
à l'automne et puis quelques jours avant
on se rendre il fallait reconfirmer et
on art confinés dans le plus grand
désordre
avec des là aussi une nappe à une
apparence d'arbitraire de compte je
laisserais mais ce qui me frappe pour
avoir retravaillé sur le h1n1
c'est qu'il y avait tout un ensemble de
tests de textes prospectifs
d'organisations y avait tout un ensemble
de schéma d'action et comment on a
révoqué a priori toute cette culture qui
avait été développé avec le h1n1 et puis
j'ai dit le vih et quand vous regardez
les textes préparatoires h1n1 y compris
les textes de la ms vous est sidéré du
fait qu'on n'a pas pris en compte cette
culture corps épais de suite appliqué
mais n'avait pas brigué le propre des
crises organisationnelles vous avez 50
conseil comité qui était prévu vous les
révoquer vous en inventer un 51e
l'occurrence tel conseil de défense et a
laissé une question l'a fait pour lui
c'est une question qu'on peut se poser
et à chaque crise organisationnel c'est
comme ça et pour terminer par rapport à
la question que vous posez on a dit
qu'on était face à l'inattendu et à
l'imprévisible c'est vrai une déferlante
cette pandémie d'une certaine manière
est venu tous les côtés et elle a
percuté la société à tous ces niveaux la
vraie question j'avais juste sur ce
point qui m'a beaucoup frappé des
départs on a mis en place à juste titre
un conseil scientifique en mars 2020
vous qui êtes féru de culture pourquoi
at-on privilégier uniquement une
approche biomédicale d'une pandémie
alors qu'on sait que c'est une salle des
knicks est un un phénomène totale et
globale pourquoi ne pas avoir sollicité
dès le départ les sciences humaines et
sociales dont on voit à quelle heure de
langue et d'une relation justement je
reviens votre affaire et il ya toute une
intelligence et était a priori révoqué
au moment même où devait la convoquer
évidemment serait justifié de la
concertation de la discussion d
arbitrage différent de ce qu'on a vu
jusqu'à présent la réponse au rapport à
la question alors crise organisationnel
- moi je ne suis pas sûr un très
honnêtement
par exemple encore une fois il faut
surtout éviter de donner toute
suggestion qu'il ya un complot quelque
part où quelque chose quelque chose de
ce type bien évidemment mais si vous
prenez pape les mesures anti terroristes
telles qu'elles ont été appliquées
d'abord aux états unis puis ensuite dans
les autres pays occidentaux
après 2001 le patriot act aux états unis
il est écrit textos en 1997 par les
services appropriés et mis en place donc
en 2001 après à la suite de ces
attentats crise organisationnel c'est
pas exactement le terme en ce qui
concerne la crise du coc vide certes
brusque fin brusque bon les mesures qui
ont été mises en place effectivement
probablement pas écrite à l'avancé telle
qu'elle est telle qu'elle était là
néanmoins néanmoins si vous voulez pour
quelqu un état quel qu'il soit pouvoir
tester en réel des mesures telles le
couvre-feu
restrictions de circulation
passe sanitaire qr code c'est ça c'est
quand même face à fait partie de l'adn
de l'état un coût mais en même temps il
ya eu notre bonjour gouverner d'autres
mesures que qu'on aurait pu s'attendre à
voir l'état prendre alors isoler les
malades par exemple on l'a jamais fait
l'application pour tracer jamais
fonctionné et c'est un jeu revient sur
les propos de monsieur hirsch
responsabiliser les gens effectivement à
un phénomène comme celui ci c'est
effectivement l' inverse de ce qui a été
fait par l'état autour de lépine mitko
vide si on prend le seul exemple du
masque par exemple c'est très
honnêtement c'est prendre les gens pour
des imbéciles vous avez effectivement un
discours qui change en fonction du temps
autour du masque vous retrouver après
avec un discours monolithique entre le
port du masque en intérieur et le port
du masque en extérieur alors que
lorsqu'on sait que la pathologie et
transmettent par transmises par des
aérosols il doit y avoir une différence
fondamentale qui est faite entre les
deux moyennant quoi vous retrouvez
aujourd'hui encore avec des gens qui
dans la rue ce travail avec des basques
est obligatoire quand même content si
oui qui a été horrible alors alors qu'il
n'y a aucune preuve scientifique
montrant que les masques en extérieur
sont utiles pour lutter contre
l'épidémie s'est
complètement l'intérieur est
actuellement par exemple de ne pas dire
aux gens que porter des masques en
extérieur ça sert strictement à rien les
laisser travailler avec des basques il y
en a aussi qui sont tout seuls dans leur
voiture avec des masques bon je ne sais
pas si c'est pas ça à prendre les gens
pour des imbéciles je sais pas ce que
c'est exactement pour revenir aussi sur
l'intervention des experts du corps
médical du cours scientifiques alors moi
je crois que le point central de samoa
g6 beaucoup dans le bouquin sur la
partie éducation bien évidemment lorsque
vous avez des experts justement qui sont
pas jeudi qu'ils savent tout sur rien
il ya une guerre morale à une très belle
formule l'aveuglément général
enveloppe la lucidité spécialisés
évidemment vous retrouver avec des
infectiologues des addictologues qui
vont avoir une très bonne compétence de
leur domaine mais qui sortis de leur
domaine aucune connaissance quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit en
épidémiologie en santé publique
aucune donc évidemment lorsque après
vous avez des gens comme ça qui vous
tombe de quelque chose comme vous disiez
tout à l'heure sur des mesures il suffit
de voir la perspicacité du conseil
scientifique de du gouvernement le
nombre de fois qu'il a préconisées lac
ou le confinement de la population
s'était quasiment enfin ça revenait tous
les tous les trois ou que tous les trois
ou six mois quoi ça c est fou et
souvenirs
oculaire venu il a dit que c'est la
moins bonne méthode ouais ouais mais sur
à l'époque c'était non mais on n'avait
pas le choix il faut il faut pas non
plus aux caractères et les choses et le
dit très bien regarder les avis ils sont
très nuancée et vous avez une
personnalité que j'aime beaucoup c'est
patrick lagadec et spécialiste de la
crise et qui avait été sur beaucoup
d'événements où la société a été
confrontée notamment aux états unis les
ouragans enfin il a travaillé ces
questions et en fin de compte ce qui m'a
beaucoup frappé le soigne on avait
travaillé entre 2006 et 2009 sur le h1n1
et tout était prêt vie prévue est
prévisible la désorganisation
les leaders charismatiques qui font ça
marseillais qui apparaissent le désordre
jusqu'à
complotite non mais tout était prévu
enfin je veux dire ce qui me frappe
c'est pourquoi on a improvisé comme on a
improvisé et pourquoi on a mis entre
parenthèses les compétences et
souleymane veut dire qu aurait pu aussi
d'un point de vue sociétal a apporté
d'acceptation sociale mais autrement que
par la contrainte et il ya un principe
qui me semble tout à fait intéressant on
verra quelles vont être les suites sur
l'avenir de notre démocratie c'est le
principe de confiance c'est à dire on a
été dans une défiance qui s'est
systématisée à travers de prise de
position politique très discutable me
semble-t-il pas ce qu'est une confusion
des genres est ce que c'était au chef de
l'état par exemple d'intervenir en tout
pour tous de faire d'épidémiologie un
jour de l'immunologie un autre jour de
faire la politique dans un contexte où
il y avait aussi des enjeux électoraux
enfin il ya beaucoup de questions qui
ont suscité une suspicion est aussi je
le vois de la part de la communauté
scientifique une forme de
désenchantement je pense juste un
exemple quand il eut le pari pour être
très concret du 29 janvier 2021 on
confine pas pour prendre un exemple
précis on peut comprendre le pari mais
il y avait d'autres côté appelé vous des
chefs de service c'était un peu
caricaturée dans le journal du dimanche
de l'ap-hp qu'on dit on va vers une
situation extrêmement difficile qu'on le
veuille ou qu'on le veuille ou pas il
n'y a pas eu la situation difficile
qu'on dit parce qu'il ya eu tout un
ensemble de pondération il ya eu des
déprogrammations donc une mortalité de
morbidité totalement dans le champ de ce
que vous dites est là on évaluera pas en
termes j'ai l'isère d'impact ce entre
guillemets qu'on a sacrifié par rapport
une lecture qui est un acteur politique
avec ses justifications à la reprise de
la société l'économie la
psychiatrisation d'un certain nombre
geder de problème c'est à dire on voyait
que la société ne tenait plus il n'y
avait plus d'acceptabilité et qu'on
allait vers une forme d'opposition en
tous les cas c'est comme ça que ça a été
interprété par les politiques ce qui
m'intéresse c'est qu'est ce qui va se
passer de décryptage intéressant dans
les mois qui viennent sur des décisions
dont aujourd'hui en 10e permet de le
sauver de la crise alors qu'on est
encore avec des risques de rebond qu'est
ce qui s'est passé réellement sur le
terrain et je vous donne juste deux
exemples qui m'ont beaucoup frappé nous
à l'espace éthique de la région ile de
france on a mis en place dès février
2020 un observatoire et donc on a
énormément de connexion avec ce qui se
passe au domicile d'un des
établissements vous avez des gens qui
sont morts socialement ça a été dit ça
m'a beaucoup frappée par les petits
frères des pauvres il ya quelques jours
dans leur rapport le 1er octobre qui a
fait apparaître qu'il y avait en france
à peu près 600 mille personnes qui
étaient en situation de mort sociale
c'est l'air de rien et tout ça a été
accentuée par ses dix-huit mois de
confinement de peur de craintes
entourent garde avec des gens d'haïti
déclare monde quel a été l'impact sur la
vie sur le quotidien de gens qui étaient
souvent en situation de survie il ya
tous ces éléments à prendre en compte et
ma critique si on veut politique c'est
de dire comment on n'a pas pu prendre en
compte percevoir ses drames ses
naufrages qui vont avoir un impact sur
la crédibilité aussi de notre démocratie
quelles que soient les solidarités
économique qu'on a mis en place parce
que parallèlement à ça on voit aussi
qu'il ya eu quand même tout un ensemble
de solidarité économique ont permis à
des gens dans les entreprises n'ont pas
de survivre mais de vivre quelques fois
d'une manière assez favorable une
période de crise il ya même certains qui
regrette le retour à la normale voilà
c'est tout ces éléments un petit peu
boutabout que je met aujourd'hui dans
l'analyse et qui devrait être repris
dans le cadre d'un retour d'expérience
au niveau politique certes mais vous
l'avez dit vous-même tout à l'heure il y
avait une urgence à prendre certaines
mesures comme par exemple confinement
qui faisait en sorte que les autres
aspects les autres conséquences de
confinement n'étaient pas prises en
compte encore fallait-il pouvoir les
présents les prendre en compte ce qui
était vraiment pas le cas mais encore
une fois donc si tout avait été pris en
compte c'est pas évident qu
effectivement le confinement soit la
meilleure solution possible à un
problème de ce type rien ne le démontre
au jour d'aujourd'hui 1 1
quand on a par exemple et si vous
demandez un effectivement responsable de
service d'infectiologie au moment du pic
de mortalité s'il faut confier la
population bien évidemment qu'ils vont
devoir répondre oui mais si vous
demandez effectivement à quelqu'un qui
s'occupe et bas de l'inactivité physique
de la dépression ou effectivement ou au
delà de la rade du dépérissement social
il va peut-être vous répondre nous donc
je ne sais pas ce qu'il faut en dire je
j'ai aussi ça m'a frappé aussi de voir
par exemple un directeur de l'ap-hp si
vous voulez qui depuis plusieurs années
participe à la réduction des moyens de
l'hôpital public de manière quand même
très significativement le nombre de deux
lits fermés depuis depuis maintenant de
nombreuses années est quand même très
important
de même que la masse salariale la
réduction de la masse salariale en
particulier du côté des infirmiers et
des infirmières
réclamer à un moment donné il faut
confiner la population a certes en effet
oui il faut confiner la population
l'épidémie de comines quand même un
point remarquable phénomène d'ampleur en
effet mais si on veut quand même
regarder les chiffres là encore les
chiffres sont très importants on a
confiné la population française lorsque
l'épidémie de kovy de
provoquer un mort par jour pour 100000
habitants
un mort par jour pour 100000 habitants
ça en effet ça sature certaines service
de réanimation
en
france la bonne question à poser
peut-être c'est pourquoi un phénomène de
ce type qui est quand même pas non plus
la fin du monde on peut dire sature des
services de réanimation est ce que les
services de réanimation sont bien
proportionnées bien dimensionné ça c'est
à mon avis des bonnes questions à poser
mais on n'a pas beaucoup été posée dans
le milieu sauf les gens directement
concernés à l'hôpital si je puis dire
j'aimerais dire à lantier le premier
confinement tout le monde était d'accord
il fallait éviter une saturation
il y avait une ambiance générale à la
fois préserver les professionnels et
préférer des capacités d'accueil
ce que je reproche finalement c'est que
l'on ose mais lorsque le premier
confinement a été arrêté on aurait pu
faire déjà un premier retour
d'expérience et se dire il y aura des
rebonds
comment la société va ce qu'est ce qu'on
est prêt à accepter comment s'organise
d'un point de vue sociétal et vous voyez
mais je veux pas détaillée mais j'ai été
très frappée et un certain nombre de
villes qui se sont mobilisés d'une
manière extraordinaire pour apporter le
soutien vital à des gens qui n'auraient
pas survécu au confinement il ya eu
toute une intelligence qu'est ce qu'on
en a fait pour préparer les phases
suivantes et qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
pour se préparer à d'autres crises parce
que n'oubliez pas une chose on
n'attendait pas la pandémie on attendait
une crise énerve essai nucléaire
radiologique bactériologique ou chimique
c'est ça qu'on attendait donc premier
point que je voulais dire par rapport à
ce que vous venez dire par rapport au
confinement par rapport à la situation
de confinement tout n'a pas été un échec
complet aussi eu des réponses politiques
de qualité et quelquefois même
transgressive par rapport à un certain
nombre d'éléments de langage on
attendait de la part des experts donc
j'applique pas la responsabilité en tout
au chef de l'état qui est destiné pour
tout ce qui me manque aujourd'hui c'est
de dire comment on a décidé ensemble et
oui ce qui m'a beaucoup frappé dans le
vih sida c'est une espèce de sentiment
même si c était aussi au très passager
de solidarité
mouvement j'allais dire sociétal
solidarité pas au début non il faudra
finalement le pour les raisons qu'on
sait
pas ce que ça touche et des groupes
étaient déjà très très marginalisés mais
oui un élément ça va faire plaisir
frédéric taddeï un des choix par exemple
dans la hiérarchisation des choix que
m'a semblé le plus scandaleux c'est la
fermeture de tout ce qui est culture et
à la mise entre parenthèses de tout ce
qui est culture à la fois parce que dans
des situations de crise on a besoin de
dépenser et je pense que la culture
c'est aussi ça de d'imaginaire le
dépassement la transcendance et la
culture et oui ça a été pour moi le
premier artiste inquiétudes ça vous
paraîtra paradoxale pour voyage était
plutôt les avions qui pouvaient plus
doués mais bon la possibilité de penser
d'une certaine manière de rester éveillé
à travers la vie culturelle aurait pu
durer toute sorte de modalités
d'expression dans le comté du
confinement donc voilà un élément qui
pour moi était tout à fait important le
deuxième élément qui ont été importants
c'est quand j'ai vu l'absence
véritablement de la vie parlementaire
par rapport à la pandémie je pense que
on avait besoin me semble-t-il dans ces
moments décisifs pour pour la société on
avait besoin d'un parlement qui est pour
fonction autre chose que d'accéder à
toutes les demandes d'une manière je les
dires passive d'une certaine façon et il
ya beaucoup d'interrogations alors je le
développe moi dans mon propos mais je
suis inquiet pour la vie démocratique
si on n'est pas en capacité ou
d'analyser comment on pourrait faire
autrement notamment du point de vue de
la vie démocratique notamment dans la
prise en compte de ce qui se passe au
plus près du terrain face à des crises
qui ne manqueront pas d'intervenir dans
les mois et les années qui viennent
alors une minute très honnêtement alors
aux deux côtés parlementaires ils sont
pas en reste par rapport aux côtés
ministériel ou
où l isère si vous regardez les rapports
de certains sénateurs par exemple
comment faire respecter les mesures de
confinement
avec un traçage permanent des individus
avec leur téléphone portable
une
alerte dès que les individus ne
respectent pas leur confinement
s'il persiste
interruption de leur titre de transport
à mende prélevée directement sur leur
sur leurs comptes bancaires voire dans
les cas extrêmes blocage du compte
bancaire ça c'est écrit un texto un
rapport publié par le sénat ya quelques
cas c'est celui où il y avait la fameuse
phrase sur la démocratie dit oui donc
très honnêtement je pense qu'ils sont
aussi fortement moteur dans l'ambiance
générale liberticide surveillance qui
s'installe dans la société alors
peut-être pas tous mais mais quand même
une partie d'entre eux juste une
question qui doit me trouverais peuvent
se blesser toutes ces mesures
discrétionnaires plus ample que des
mesures qui ont été mises en place par
le gouvernement est ce que c'est que les
gens qui se posent la question dans une
situation qui lui un train plus
dramatique est ce qu'elle se
justifierait pas mais c'est une question
ok pas philosophique là on est à un
premier niveau en deuxième niveau un
troisième niveau mais dans une situation
plus dramatique regardez par exemple
ebola on n'aurait pas eu
la situation avec la cuvée 19 on aurait
eu ebola est ce que vous pensez que nos
règles démocratiques nos principes
d'éthique résisterez à une déferlante de
cette nature et moi je me pose la
question pour l'avenir ce sera la
question sur laquelle nous resterons à
la fin de cette émission merci tous les
deux d'avoir participé à ce débat merci
de nous avoir suivis et rendez vous au
prochain numéro
[Musique]